[Music]
[Music]
seriously midge you completely freaked
us out on the season one finale of the
ælis we did not see that coming at all
you left us with a literal and
metaphorical cliffhanger you became a
master at foreshadowing when you said
what we eat is dead and gone is only
lost for a while we were all shocked to
find out exactly what you meant by the
start and foreboding line there are some
major well moments at the end of the
ælis season one we also found some
surprising clues about what's to come in
season two watch until the end to find
out the biggest secret we unearthed how
did what warning spoilers ahead the
a-list just came out on Netflix in the
US and Canada we have re devoured the
first season and are totally hooked on
the show quick recap a group of teens go
to a remote island for a summer camp
adventure tensions rise between the two
queen bees of the camp amber and Mia Mia
seems to be the only one who gets how
dangerous amber truly is it all leads to
a shocking season one finale that no one
could have ever predicted here's the
ending explain watch until the end for
some major secrets about what's to come
in season 2 the boat Harry and kettle
make a hurried escape off the island
just out of reach from Amber's mindwiped
minions huddle is worried that she may
never see Alex again we don't know how
far they get or if they will completely
make it away from the island we have a
prediction about the fate of Harry and
petal watch until the end to find out
what it is Luca we all released a sigh
of relief when Luca rescued Mia at the
last minute he tricked everyone when he
said with the arrow he fired was a
warning shot we learned later that it
was his only arrow Luca has a major
crush on Mia this sets up a love
triangle for season two now that Deb's
mind is no longer wiped by Amber will
Maya go back to death or has she
developed feelings for Luca we bet she
will go with Luca since he saved her
life
Alex and Mia in the first episode we
thought that Nia and Caylee were going
to be best friends Alex and Mia would
like oil and water in the beginning but
by the end of the first season their
bond was stronger than ever now that
Amber is no longer controlling Kaylee's
it's going to be interesting to see the
friend dynamic between these three but
there is an even more unlikely
friendship we've got our eyes on for
season two stay tuned to find out who
we're talking about the power switch
everyone was holding their breath as Mia
walked toward the cliffs edge on Amber's
command we didn't know how Mia was going
to get out of that one we all saw that
glimmer in her eye when she realized
that amber had no power over her that
power switch was everything we just hope
Mia is powerful enough to defeat midge
does anyone else freaked out when she
climbed up onto the edge of the cliff
that was the stuff of nightmares
but is migi good or evil watch until the
end to see our prediction the injection
raise your hand if you cheered when Alex
injected amber with mags aminos team
formula we almost felt bad for amber
when she was lying on the ground
recovering we thought it was all over
when she said midge is gone but Mitch
most certainly is not gone and
apparently she has some bizarre
supernatural abilities yikes we didn't
see that one coming
midges final line we felt the hairs on
our next stand up as midge sneered
saying her final line you have no idea
Mitch climbed up the cliff and scared
the bejesus out of everyone at the end
of the last episode that line is loaded
with foreshadowing of a dark future for
the campers at pare grind it implies
that Alex and Mia thought they were
doing the right thing by injecting amber
with mags formula but they have no idea
what they've really done it seems like a
fate that is far worse than anything
they can imagine so what's going to
happen in season two here are our
predictions prediction one enemies
become friends to defeat the evil that
is haunting Peregrine former enemies
will have no choice but to team up even
the ones who couldn't stand each other
in the first season we're talking about
amber and Mia if they want to defeat
midge or whatever evil is lurking in the
shadows of the island they're going to
have to swallow their pride and come
together addiction to hairy and petal
hairy & petal got away too easy we
predict that their boat stops working
and they will have to swim back to the
island it's the only thing that makes
sense
Harry is everyone's favorite and petal
just has to be reunited with Alex
prediction 3 the real villain midge is
not the real
remember when mags explains that her
mysterious employer is fascinated by the
amber Mia dynamic they refused to rescue
the campers because they didn't want to
spoil their research opportunity yet
after amber was neutralized by Max's
formula the company notified mags that
they were coming we think midge is just
a part of the larger experiment that
Max's mystery employer is the real
villain what do you guys think about the
first season and which couple are you
shipping the most sound off in the
comments subscribe to the things to be
the first to see our latest videos and
while you're at it click on the thumbs
up button thanks for watching bye
[Music]